remember we had a video on top 10
transformations well guess what here we
go with the transformations again 10
wasn't nearly enough to cover all of the
epic transformation that animes gifted
us for the past few decades so why don't
we have a second go at it without
further ado let's get the show on the
road
[Applause]
for show that deals with clothing so
much I kind of wonder how it took two
volumes of this list to include an entry
from kill la kill but much of the series
we've known the two characters as mortal
enemies contrasting each other they're
seemingly built to be rivals however as
the story heads towards the climax
Ryoko and Satsuki have patched things up
and find themselves standing side by
side for the final battle this is one of
the coolest transformation scenes in the
show given how it symbolizes their
newfound sisterhood and bond Plus who
doesn't like killer kills fanservice II
transformation sequences this is
definitely a top moment of the show
especially we don't lose your way
blaring in the back as the sisters
transform into their ultimate forms
ninth on the list is something that's
probably still fresh on the minds of the
show's fans at sushis transformation in
the finale of bungo stray dogs what a
way to end a season in style most of you
probably know him as a weretiger so his
ability pretty much already involves a
transformation well then how about a
transformation born of a dream team up
with his rival in the climax Akutagawa
passes him Rashomon his shadow cloak
what comes of it is a brand new
transformation for our hero one born of
the fusion of the two contrasting
abilities instead of the usual Tiger
form he usually takes art sushis final
transformation in season 3 is the
combination of his and a good the
gaara's powers
[Music]
next up is cars and his transformation
in battle tendency so the story here is
that cars has just come from a grueling
battle against Joseph after jobbing to
Joseph's Harmon and having his blade
broken in the process the end seems near
for the leader of the pillar men it's
time for the Nazis good guys by the way
to finish the job
Stroheim orders his men to unleash
ultraviolet light but to their horror
Kars equips a stone mask and turns the
light into a catalyst for his
transformation everyone looks on in
horror as Kars triumphantly stands in
the midst of his all the exterminated
minions as the ultimate big please you
think that puny Nazi beams would get the
job done here it takes more than light
shows to finish off an entity of cares'
caliber as they say what doesn't kill
you makes you stronger and thanks to
those guys Kars rises once more with
renewed strength things go from bad to
worse as Kars the ultimate being is born
to cause trouble for our heroes
[Music]
coming in at 7:00 is a classic use gaze
demon transformation this particular
moment happened during chapter black
where you skate unveiled his demon
transformation against sin sweet in the
final fight against sin sweet you scape
finds himself in quite a pickle he's
done his best in fighting on par with
sensory but as their isolated battle
rages on it's still anyone's game
that's when Rison decides to show up and
take over giving you skate of brand-new
demon transformation that seriously
reminds me of Super Saiyan modes doesn't
it remind you of Super Saiyan 5 or
something it's a no-holds-barred
beatdown girl or as you skate destroys
sensory with his new powers now that's
what you get for under estimating the
greatest spirit detective in his powered
up form
[Music]
at 6 we have Aaron's transformation in
episode 24 of attack on Titan by this
time we all know that Titans are pretty
much flesh and bones mecha and the air
in our protagonists can transform into
one of them that's got to be common
knowledge to most fans at this point
right however what makes this
transformation in episode 24 extra
special is the context that surrounds it
Aaron finds himself unable to manually
activate his transformation much of it's
caused by the shock of finding out
Annie's identity as the female Titan so
due to this Aaron finds himself unable
to fight and let's not kid ourselves the
last time we tried fighting the female
Titan he got beaten so hard he pulled an
infinity war hulk way before 2018
luckily for him he has his pal by his
side to snap him out of his doubts that
pal is of course not armed in for his
rage
remember he gets hatred for the smiling
Titan that killed his mother Aaron
finally enters his time to inform once
more determined to finally stop Annie
once and for all he charges the female
Titan with no hesitation
before we continue I'd like to thank the
sponsor of this video kog games their
game L swords are free-to-play 2.5 D
action MMORPG
which features real-time action gameplay
and includes both player versus
environment and player versus player
modes this long-running games about to
receive a massive character reboot
update that transforms its characters in
the way you play them all characters
base stats will now be standardized set
to identical levels across all
characters and there'll be emphasis on
differentiating each character path by
increasing the respective stat that
matches to play L sword you just have to
click the link in the video description
and download the game
the end of the season really felt like
the beginning of a new chapter for Tokyo
ghoul in many ways it is especially when
you consider that the series ends with
Kenickie finally accepting his gold
heart
and during young Morrie's torture
Carnegie was finally driven to accept
that side he'd shunt for so long
connect he finally gains access to a
form that fans have been waiting 12
episodes for in the first season's
finale
yamori had created his worst nightmare
as Kenickie in this new form dishes out
a curb-stomp battle the torture had
broken the former hesitant boy and
finally awakened the monster within him
the climactic battle of the awakened
Carnegie and yamori is made better with
unravel a song with lyrics that seem
tailor-made just for this scene Kenickie
ends the batter with a ruthless streak
consuming yahwah's kagune
[Music]
Scottie you
[Music]
Waring on the creek up
[Music]
and they'll pass the halfway mark and we
have Naruto's transformation versus pain
and number four we said rage is the most
powerful trigger for unlocking potential
in anime and in addition to Eren we have
Naruto as another testament to that this
form appeared when pain seemingly killed
Hinata in front of Naruto probably one
of the most chilling transformation
sequences in the series consumed with
anger the seal that binds the Kyuubi
within Naruto begins to unravel and he
lets anger feed into the monster inside
him slowly releasing one tail after
another [ __ ] just got real and it speaks
volumes that this is the last time that
Naruto forced someone while filled with
rage gotta mister time drink UB was a
terrific demonic Fox entity inevitably
cuz she had to give the QB a personality
in some development over the course of
the series but the transformations
during the early phase of Naruto really
drove home the fact that the tailed
beasts are like forces of nature and
containable uncontrollable and
unstoppable taking the number-2 spot
is Batman femto griffiths transformation
into femto is a key turning point for
the character in the Eclipse arc
Griffith is frankly a shell of his
former self and no sacrifice seems too
great when it comes to getting another
shot at his dream with nothing to lose
at this point
sacrificing his friends in order to
become a demon gods an easy decision to
make and it leads the way to an
extremely iconic moment in berserk his
transformation into femto as Griffiths
transforms you say that he felt a slight
bit of remorse which was quickly cast
aside everyone knows there's just no
turning back from this this is the birth
of a demon God with an army at his core
who ashes in an age of darkness
[Music]
[Music]
move over Super Saiyan we have a cool
new Dragonball transformation in town
ultra instinct it triumphantly stands
atop volume two of top ten
transformations I find it fitting that
the new Dragon Ball series would come up
with another transformation for our hero
ultra instincts a new power that was
first revealed during the tournament of
power and it's a form that Goku can
access not a will but out of necessity
in this case it's the battle against grn
that allows him to shatter his limits
and tap into this new form I was to find
it poetic that ultra instinct being
touted as Goku's most powerful form
barely transforms him instead of getting
his signature Super Saiyan hair or other
peripherals ultra instinct simply
surrounds Goku in a white aura and
whatever transformations the body gets
really look tame compared to what we're
used to honestly I think that's what
makes this transformation so awesome you
don't have to see the power manifest in
physical transformations but you can
simply feel it by looking at Goku in
this form
[Music]
with that we wrap up this list just like
the last time I asked you this question
which one among these transformations is
your favorite don't hesitate to let your
opinions be heard throughout the
comments section if you've got more
suggestions for your future content I'd
love to hear from you too don't forget
to check out our sponsors game Elsword
links in the description that's it for
now and I'll see you next time on Vinnie
tube
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]